read we know that battery technology
isn't really keeping up with other other
advances in smartphone technology but
how did that result in these massive
problems of Hsiang Hsiang
and of course that note 7 yeah it looks
like a combination of issues one is the
battery is bigger in the note 7 by as
much as 15 to 20 percent from its
predecessor and even compared to the
larger iPhone the iPhone 7 plus against
which it is competing on top of that
people want these batteries to charge
faster that's partly to deal with the
fact that they don't last as long and
then another factor is you know there's
a push for slimmer and slimmer phones
and so you're trying to cram a lot of
power a lot of functionality into a
tighter space and this I think was one
of the major reasons why we've had so
many issues with the note 7 and and the
recall Tebbe something here you know
read is it an issue with the design
manufacturing or technology that has
been causing these problems yes so at
this point what we know is that Samsung
SDI it's an affiliate of the electronics
manufacturer was making the batteries
there was several reports but they
mostly point toward a sort of a membrane
that separates the positive and negative
terminals within the battery that seemed
to have failed or not worked properly in
some way and so what you essentially get
is a short circuit and and we're talking
about a lot of volatile and sensitive
chemicals and materials within the
battery causes a chain reaction and and
an electrical fire so that that's really
what seems to be the issue now Samsung
has already said publicly that they're
switching to a lot of new suppliers and
so they seem to have figured out the
problem at the very least right now what
changes might we see what might we see
as a result of this exploding phone
episode I mean the reality is is that we
are at the limits of battery technology
the material sciences is just coming up
against them you know very hard sort of
physical rules and unless we see a lot
of new materials our new kind of ideas
into the state come into this space
we're not going to see an improvement
anytime soon because a lot of these
technological advances and batteries
take you know 10 15 plus years to
develop so what we will probably see as
other ways to deal with the issue for
example a better software and and
processors that that use much less power
essentially trying to squeeze a more
life out of what is very fairly limited
technology in terms of providing
Lacrosse electricity to the you know
tablets and smartphones that everyone
seems addicted to